with me oh you have little we have water
should I put should I put one should I
put a label around no you're fine yeah a
lots changed since you did this last
this is actually this is called they're
called pontus water they're a local
spring water from the Blue Ridge
Mountains of Georgia whoo-hoo done
everybody loves me uh but innies will
not let me live my life after day I
don't know I know last time you banged
and now you're all you got the full get
up that a fool we balaji oh but this is
this is where it's gonna be like posted
this is just live to show how many
people don't care on the Facebook's and
Instagram
has it started yet yeah hmm oh there
yeah there's people in here yeah but um
so this one will go on YouTube they are
we talking about P no okay I waited till
after okay don't worry
yeah now they brought it up where you
talking about P oh yeah and this is
guinnesses first appearance on not
hungry you are out of control
oh let me um hey dog let me turn us down
don't stay as if he's trained stay hello
and you had guinness the whole we've had
on like two months we rescued him no
yeah he got like hit by a car
so he has like he had surgery and we've
been nursing him back to health
it's his first hot breath cameos it's a
big day do you have a dog I do not you
know I
my family had a pet for years that I
should not be talking into the
microphone dramatically
so just talk towards it a rescue purse
from Goodwill you know my my parents had
a dog for um four years we had a Jack
Russell that we was very fat and
overweight his name was cows or Jackson
were you feeding a human food he just
was fat hmm no that was the one dog that
we actually like bought dog food for
like oh he was the you know people
always like like people feed her dogs
real fun I wasn't gonna say anything I
just cuz I know what the people know
what the people are singing I'm here to
tell you though about for you where am I
looking
listen pee yeah let the hump at the
verse no my parents haven't they had a
dog rest his soul but we actually cared
about him to the vet so Wow yeah we yeah
hehe but yeah he he was like yeah but he
had he a special dog food like his own
room was this in Columbus is he looking
[Music]
he's never been around he's only been
around my wife and she's married so he's
[Laughter]
is this safe for work was that angle
safe for work just your dog Jack
rustling how you actually cared for them
yeah well yeah I mean he I mean my
parents had a dog when I was younger
they had a Doberman named Asia Minor
uh-huh and then I'm pretty certain I'm
neighbor poisoned him Oh what's this is
back in Columbus Georgia uh Miss Georgia
years ago the I don't hand the other
side I know I know who did it
oh really I do Savage I hope they're not
watching right now clearly I'm sure
statute of limitations probably right in
a minute
oh yeah when I was about three so I
should okay
I'm old nails and here what 21 right so
Aneta 21 was though happy birthday
18 years ago guys this is very exciting
and it's Jackson oh no you've never
heard that before I love it up but
somebody just recently was like oh you
always come up to that song and I was
like I'm dumb like why didn't I think
okay yeah do you do the kind of shows
that come out to like DJ's even always
yeah no no no no never
music shows but because it's a specific
type of show sometimes even clubs will
do it now though I guess yeah I mean I
think it gives a little oomph to going
on yeah age way momentum and a little
energy yeah I know wish that's because I
could probably just sit like this good
night you could yeah I think it'll be
fine it'll pick you out oh yeah yeah
long way this is now my equipment you're
right you did episode five and it wasn't
even my equipment I was borrowing
equipment from like a sound engineer I
don't know no it was borrowed yeah it
was not mine and now we're out here
we're doing video and we're live in and
we're why we got water in it's it's all
legit that's for you you got labeled
water yeah anybody can do it with Von
Teese that's our sponsor cool and then
I'll add a thing in post that flashes it
up between us they didn't even ask me to
do that I just thought it would be cold
so it's very exciting to catch up with
you because when I interviewed you last
you you were just you hadn't even
appeared on Last Comic Standing I had
not you had taped it mm-hmm and that was
aired exactly and now it's aired and you
seem to be building momentum this was
this was I posted it August of 2015 just
to give a context maybe even know how
far ago that was yes they did just um so
yeah it would have come able to start a
nearing that July happening uh oh yeah
or maybe I did the interview before it
aired and then posted it after it aired
maybe I did that just for you
because so many people were listening
right guys are gonna make sure NBC
doesn't get on the hot trail but we're
here now we are and how is how is the me
averse house it is um traumatic
traumatic no is it no driven you know
I've just been um just working I mean
that's really just kind of just awesome
working and I'm like I you know I don't
have a residence in Atlanta anymore and
so I sort of kind of am in DC quite a
bit and I'm in DC so I can go to New
York until I can get my life together to
go I officially live here now oh okay
it's like a transitional yes way there
mhm so it was pretty good cuz I can get
there and I mean it's pretty easy to get
you from DC so hmm no just go in there
and and work when I can and for New York
and like film know just like Cup clubs
and stuff yeah oh yeah what is the
transition Ben because at that moment
you were almost transitioning out of
your corporate work into like here I go
how well you are doing that this now Ben
that was April of 2014 that's crazy yeah
I steal Kenny yeah I am it's been pretty
interesting because it all happened so
fast cuz it was like April 2014
um wait was that yeah April 2014 job all
that stuff happening the job where they
were like we hate you and I was like
pursuit is acquiring the quit firing I
like to come on you should work at
another department and I was like or not
here at all and so um
so by that fall I had already you know I
knew I was gonna be on Last Comic
Standing and then it was just just stuff
just started happening back to back to
back and you know and then like it's
been that long and I'm and it was the
one of the crazy things like around it
time I had just two or three months
beforehand I wanting out a brand new car
and I'm just like cuz clearly this I'm
gonna be working to this job forever
right and then I was like oh my god I
don't have a
how what am I gonna do with her but mama
been able to make them pavement oh snap
yeah I am yeah so was been and I
remember somebody saying to me like why
are you gonna pay for your car and I was
like with muddy from comedy - yeah yeah
so it's been good just to be like wow
I've been able to get stuff done you
know and so um but yeah just stuff just
you know but now like I said I'm just
kind of just working just trying to just
get a foothold wherever I can and harass
people and maleta me headline and that's
what I was gonna ask about is actually
I'm I'm now a little over eight years in
hmm and I just did my taxes and I was
like Oh mm I need money
[Laughter]
[Music]
like oh I'm over eight years in now I
was like okay I've been okay okay maybe
it's time to actually like I'm full-time
in comedy but it's all been like since
I've gone full time it's all just been
sustaining might just keep my head above
water got you know wiggle room and now
it's like you know what I should this
should be like a productive profession
right like I should get a profit exactly
yeah yeah not you know and not be paying
it to Sallie Mae aka my wife that's so
that's fortunate that you know I now
live where I live with her cuz I got
married since we did the interview as
well so we're all good over a year well
over a year April 1st 2017 did it I feel
like it happened in 2016 but it's your
life and I yeah we had Griff Griff was
the efficient of our wedding really yeah
a comedian Griff yeah it was funny but
yeah I cried and then he booed me it was
he I did cry I cried a lot yeah he steal
my heart I was reading my own vows and I
got like I was struggling to get through
it
he just like booed me he's like come on
homie please tell me you have footage of
this I don't have footage of this I've
put photos why did you not get a
videographer I don't know I
these aren't listen when you plan a
wedding and you didn't think about there
are so many all I did was be like okay
here's the spreadsheet she sent me today
whatever's on here okay cool I'll get
that done I'm not worried about what or
when I'm just worried about she sent me
this okay I will do this you just
followed rules yeah wedding planning if
you can survive that you can survive in
there yeah I've seen it tap and I've
been I never got around to it which is
why yo stack of books and I was like
literature yeah gotta read but it was
like checklist of you know how to do all
these things on a motor now or I could
just not do this at all
yeah and save myself a lot of stress
like heck yeah so since then now that I
do have a wife have a dog you know have
a family provide for I'm I'm trying to
be and you know just for the sake of
being a comedian I want to be able to
like you said turn a profit make it a
business so you saying you know what
I've just been working you make a sound
like it's magic and it just it's easy to
make happen how have you been able to
generate this like and spare no detail
you know I would probably say I would
think for me it's been just a level of
consistency mm-hmm I think yeah give the
people because as we all know I murder
okay no let's not sure no no no I'm I
think I'm okay fine I think I'm
cold-blooded oh look I'm alright but I
think but I do think I'm but when I say
consistency I mean just as far as like
the professionalism part just going I
show up when I'm supposed to if I've
been told and do a certain amount of
time or if I've been told not to do a
certain amount of time then you just
follow directions and that's kind of
usually what I tell people all the time
I'm like just follow directions I
that will make things a lot easier just
you know and so um and in order times
are maybe have gone a minute or two over
sure but it doesn't happen often stir
stick to the light but yes normally yeah
but if people ask you to you know hey
are you gonna you know these are the
dates that I booked you sure you know
book to you you show up and you do the
job that you got asked to do and don't
tear up things when you get there don't
be destructive towards people you know
just then just be cool I mean that's
that's kind of the thing I've always
been like it's just follow directions be
cool and also remember you know it still
work like it right you'll you know yeah
work but it's a it's a job that you you
know if you care about Connery like
Haiti but this is a job I care about and
when he came to my corporate job when it
was like oh you should be on time I was
like no I'm not I'm not gonna do that
I'm not gonna show up here on top or do
what I'm supposed to do uh-huh or work
the hours that you want me to work I
don't want to be here but for things
that I care about it's like you know
what just follow directions
you know you do enough to get invited
back how are you able to find these to
begin with what just the rules are they
not like the big like for me a lot of it
has been like I guess just kind of
building up a lot of groundwork while I
had the corporate job so just knowing
people working people but again I think
the reason why people ask me to do
things because they went oh she solid
you know or it might have been someone
that I worked with it you know punchline
laughing school or somewhere who's like
oh yeah I remember her or next time I
come to town I should request that
person to host I should request that
person to feature and then that person
might go oh have you ever come to
such-and-such let me you know and
they'll just refer you know if I get a
lot of referrals and then you know just
people going oh you should book me and
then I'll reach out to those people and
sometimes they emailed me back and
sometimes they don't
and sometimes they book you to open up
at Phillips Arena humor at night
Oh white people look the same though
someone someone you knew was there right
because I remember someone telling you
the next day or something I mean um I
saw you the next day or I did I saw you
a punch line
yes that was because you went from Amy
Schumer Phillips Arena to punch line
with 20 people
yeah that's comedy right got features
yeah feature like that
Thursday and Friday I think and in
Saturday I did the show with her this
Sunday I came back you're like hey I
thought you were yeah and I was like I
was at Phillips really I did make it yes
but that is comedy yeah yeah she's been
very very helpful to me and that was
just been like I can't say enough like
she's been super cool but but that's how
I met her though from working at the
punch line and her being like oh I like
you like are you hosting tomorrow night
and you know so okay I think you should
you know or you know come back again am
i okay and that's that's how I met her
yeah yeah so just having some home
training what have you learned from even
just being us being around comedians I
haven't been around our work to smite
her caliber but even just higher caliber
comedians I'm always looking to see what
I can learn from them what can I absorb
even if I don't specifically ask them
things it's just seeing how they move
and how they operate what have you
learned about and being in her orbit um
like it's just a lot of moving parts I
mean because you know a lot of people
think like you just get on stage and
that's all there is to but like you know
when I see her my she's like all this
stuff going on like you know just this
just everything happening all at once
but she still is like alright I'm gonna
go out there and do this show and you
know and I mean but on that level
obviously it's other stuff that comes
into play right you know it's road
managers and you know I love this track
different kind of stuff yeah so but it's
cool like to see that to go oh so that
kind of helps keep a lot of the you know
a lot of stuff that we would deal with
where you're like oh did I better give
him a bag or did I bring my rod I bring
my merch or where's this thing or you
have somebody that's like oh this cool
thing is already being done like I just
work with our senior Hall recently yeah
yes you know
at Morty's in like his assistant like he
just made everything like just mu just
super super smooth and it was just like
oh this is what happens when you can
just you just walk in and dear said I
mean you know but is but it's cool to
see like well on that level like okay
you have some kind of a buffer between
like some of the stuff that could
normally stress you out it's like oh you
get to go up here and just relax you can
have fun and you know you're not having
to worry about just like drop some book
hotel that I do this thing that do you
know cuz yeah in my head I'm always like
looking at notes and going
that thing is checked off that being is
checked out but it's like you got that
person there to go I can help make your
life easier so which is really cool like
seeing like like oh this is what happens
when somebody's like big-time you know
like oh you know in isostatic yeah yeah
and then you know and but just from a
business standpoint to I mean not you
know when when somebody else is speaking
on your behalf that sometimes makes
things a lot easier too because hmm you
know I mean I've you know just in
general from working in close where I
hear people go well if you worked with
someone so er this person's rude or this
person that because but it's because
that person might be asking for that
thing themselves but when you know or if
I ask for something myself like hey can
I get it
water you know like she's an answer for
water you know but then like if you came
from a business and it'll be like you
know miss Jackson means water right know
what I mean so it's kind of it's just so
that's the like when I see that level
I'm like oh like it's a like there's
things to help kind of keep people you
know insulated from just yeah so for you
can night really just focus on the craft
and the heart and all that kind of star
they going through show notes as well
like really in that and that much in
especially her would nose like I know I
think that I see uh yeah I mean I may
have seen I don't think I saw Arsenio
wit nose but I mean I know he like but
you know he watched me you know and had
some notes for me you know that was cool
so yeah but I like that to it it's like
you'd like there's such a stress relief
off of you know when you get to that
level where you can go I can watch other
people sits and you know you know cuz
sometimes though in my head before said
to where I'm like I can't listen to that
person I can't lose to this person until
my fingers Dylan you know so that's a
you know cooling to her you're like oh I
got this big-time person can look at me
and go
I'll give you notes and in fact actually
that made me think about something else
which is jumping around but what I did
jfl this past you're like just for
laughs yeah yeah no big deal no big deal
but like I I was actually um they you
know they um you know we could ask for
feedback on our sets and then so she you
know Amy asked me was like oh what are
you what are you gonna do in your
setting I was like if you don't mind
would you read over the note so she was
like yeah absolutely so it was just
super cool to go I got one of the
biggest comedians right now to go I will
look over yourself for you so huh
yeah what kind of feedback did you get
um just like you know just talking about
like the order of the staff she was like
everything disorders good she was like I
think this joke she's like this line
right here is killer
this one is kill look I think this is a
good six minutes and I'm like I mean
take anything out I need to keep you
know and it was just really cool to go
wow like she actually took time to reach
down and help me so and I think that's
moving to when people get to that level
as well where it's like um you know the
people that are the good people I think
in the business that are like I will
always turn around to help somebody to
you know you would think that if
somebody's that usually like I have time
for those things but I think that's the
thing that I've learned to to go oh I
should always I'll help a lot of people
anyway all the time anyway yeah mama
means everybody always be asking now
which I don't but but um but it just
made me go like okay well I'm doing the
right thing like if if people that are
the million steps ahead of me can reach
back and he'll then I'm on the right
path that I'm always helping people to
yeah that's what I've noticed even in
booking this podcast is I'll reach out
you know I'm I'm not shy about reaching
out like do a moon shot and just reach
out to a big comedian who's in town or
whatever or to their management mmm-hmm
and just seeing the behaviors of I'll
reach out to a big level person they may
say no but they respond and I'll reach
out like a lower level person just like
oh yeah I'll just get that they don't
even respond yeah yeah and it's like
okay so those are the kind of behaviors
that get you to beyond just like this
level or whatever yeah so you saw that's
what I would say just like the you know
the cuz I I mean obviously when you see
people who are you know famous and stuff
you knew that they did the hard work but
but like I said to me is those other
things that that I'm watching more like
oh look at what she did or look at what
he did and you know cuz even went on
when I did the shows um Arsenio's the
system was like oh yeah you know you
actually had a note for you for when
you're adults and I was like like he's
like I can't room what it was about I'll
get it from him and I'm just wrong like
like he looked he was watching my said
you know like you know it was just
really cool to go like you know like
that's cool but the cool thing to do so
you're worse is I try you know which I
mean we are in you are you're you're
like a professional working comedian
like it's it's cool to see your progress
from just seeing you at open mikes to
now you're like oh you know I've just
been working you're like it's you know
just working no no I talked to Landry
I've talked to Landry because he's being
on the cruise ships now it's like how
he's talking about it now it's almost
like a job he's like yeah yeah just
clocking in on the cruise go and do your
work and you try to you know and then
and I still like feel like I'm trying to
get better you know like I mean I'd like
that to me that part never stops you
know so it's like I just keep worked in
and keep trying how about the rebook is
what I've heard is like the most
important part getting booked once but
the rebook is where you start to build
yeah just you know it to me and I have
had some problems with following up as a
person um that is something like
sometimes I'll be like I'm gonna email
that person then I'll go but but I do
try to UM I do try to be like as soon as
I work somewhere you know I will try to
send an email afterwards or text or
something go thank you so much for let
me work you know hey I would love to
come back again you know oh yeah let me
know in this I try to give it enough a
reasonable enough amount of time to like
I'm not gonna email them back like the
next week and go hey whatever their date
you know but like you know says I know
clubs would try to bring special with
features they'll bring somebody back you
know a person might come back three or
four times a year but we had lines and
let me maybe just twice a year so it's
like okay you know what I should
probably you know what when did I last
work in a club I last worked them in
July I have enough time to I can send
another email and you know follow up and
see what they're thinking now you know
do you have a calendar set up of your
dates and I do I do you know what a
night
yeah so detail wise actually shout-out
to my boo for that he was the he would
um because I would get frazzled all the
time where I would have a because one
cool tip I picked up from Landry back in
the day one he's me roommates he would
um he would keep a big dry erase board
calendar on the wall and it would just
he would write out all those dates on
there and you know so that way if he was
you know sitting at home or something
and somebody called he's good-looking oh
okay I got something such we go but I
got this date opener so I started doing
that but then um then but for me I still
sometimes have to rise to it to
physically write stuff down so I can go
I wrote it I committed it to memory but
my um my boobs like listen why don't you
just why don't you put that in your
google calendar he's like you know you
you use Google for everything else so
like put everything in your calendar and
when I say everything is in there like
everything like I mean I have not that
this has anything to do with comedy but
like I have my bills are in there like
my due dates for bills you know because
it when I first went full-time it would
be like when I had my day job in my head
I would go you know what I gotta pay
Capital One on the 15th I remember that
but then as I started getting busier I
would go oh wait what day is it did I do
that thing so like I have a separate
calendar for all my personal stuff and
then I have a separate calendar under
another account for my comedy stuff so
like every so everything is color-coded
so anything that's comedy related is in
a certain color and that's whether I'm
gonna do a podcast whether it was I'm
gonna meet with someone about something
like my week you know for if I'm working
at a club for a week then that's all in
my calendar believe you know I but
I have both of them displayed so that I
can see like oh this is what's going on
my personal life at that same time so
will I be able to make this thing or
that thing work or not work so do you
take a day to just inventory the week or
how do you organize your time with that
yeah I will um you know just to you know
every couple of weeks I'll go back and
you know try to make sure like okay do I
have this thing in here did I Drive who
do I need to follow it with and I write
this thing down you know so I will go
back and check just to make sure then I
might go back and look to go what was I
doing last year at this time that I'll
go back later okay that's when I worked
at such-and-such you know what yeah like
it should be a good enough time now to
email this person and say can I come
back no how do you drum up the new work
just asking people really like if I know
my friends have worked somewhere like if
you have a friend that's a that I know
is a headliner and they don't mind
bringing me as a feature then I might
just be like hey you know if you don't
have anybody come with you can I come or
if I friend it is a headliner they might
go well you need to come here as a
feature like I'll just give them your
info and you follow it with him yourself
so I you know kind of go check out my
friends calendars or just ask them I hey
who are you um who are you working with
right now like what club did you just
work okay cool that a cool club like in
you know if you don't mind would you
share the contact info with me I know
that cuffing which also there needs to
be some etiquette around it for people
to ask for that kind of stuff too like
don't just be like give me our info you
know so if there's people I'm cool with
this a lot of stuff like I'm do you know
Trey black you know yeah yeah ever when
I first started comedy you telling me
tell me all the time he used to go work
gets work work gets work and so it was
like oh okay you know what so if I'm
working with somebody and if I talk to
another comic I'm actually gonna get
most of my work from other comics no
does that seem to be true now at this
level of your career oh yeah yeah cuz
I'm trying to think of all the things
that I've done like like I said it's my
stuff that Amy's referred me to that
I've gotten to do is been on like Drew
Thomas like we just worked together last
weekend hilarities and Cleveland so I
he'll Gore he'll work somewhere be like
oh you know what I got to get you into
such a such club or or if I go work such
as
Club how about next time I go I'll bring
you the feature so they can see that
you're a strong you can actually you
know you're strong feature but they'll
see you can actually hit line so you you
know he's brought me with him the stuff
so you know just people tell them like
oh you got to hit up this person or you
should call this person but and then
every once in a while I'll get somebody
contacting me on my website would it be
like hey are you
you know we saw your videos and blah
blah blah and like the best yeah the
website messages are always unique
they are the sometimes they are strange
[Music]
more often than not I've gotten um
specifically older white man with
glasses like to email me quite a bit not
about work just like huh yes all your
videos when I was hoping you were going
to be in Montana so and I'm like no I
will never be there not for you no but I
do get but I do get you know I'll get
requests sometimes well hey I saw you
wants us in touch or hey I heard about
you from this person you know or they
might have seen me at a show and you're
like her website must be me at
jackson.com I'll send her a message so
yeah and even going on your website even
just preparing for this interview I saw
you now have management I do go in the
game it's the same agency that has like
Gabriel Iglesias
it's like Jo koy and a bunch of cool
people on there how did you or how did
cuz that's it's like one thing to like
be a comedian who's featuring around the
country would ever make a new band then
you're now it's like it's almost like
another plateau yeah yeah um another
tier not plateaus yeah yeah but like
initially mad initially met her cuz she
manages the well-read guys you know
pretty crowded yeah yeah so it was
something they were doing and they
recommended me to her to like do
whatever this thing was with them comic
recommendation yeah call back yeah and
so that's when I initially met her and
you know I was like oh I she's cool
she's super nice she's great and then we
cheeto you know I always keep in touch
and I would just sometimes like hey I
got a question like you're a manager
maybe you could like do you know how
should
this thing you know I'll just ask her
questions sometimes and then and then
like after I did J I feel because I went
I did new faces unwrapped so I didn't
have management or anything when I went
in and so shortly after Jo feels she's
like you know but it's not matter just I
met her like a year and a half before
almost so yeah and when you say
contacting her in the meantime is just
do social media or you have email yeah
just yeah like facebook Messenger where
I would be like you know just you know
cuz there's certain people that I've met
just throughout the years of my cave you
don't mind like can I run this by you or
do you think this sounds crazy or you
know I want to ask your advice as a you
know a person being on the you know the
business side of things like yeah can
you give me some advice on this thing or
that thing so but this is like after
you've met them in person
yeah yeah cling these people yeah
audience yeah like don't just be finding
people and bothering them right no like
it right connection is very important
meeting with people talking to people
and actually having that you know
face-to-face like oh hey Joel cuz now
you know I could go maybe I want to do a
podcast but I can reach out to you about
hope directly I've had so many people
reach out although like tips on how to
start one but yeah but like just yeah
just cold calling I mean I don't I mean
it I don't really recommend it I I just
kind of feel like you should establish
some kind of connection with people
before you just hit yes and have
etiquette in your mess man yeah and if
you do cold call have some etiquette
about it but yeah I mean I like that I
get you know people to hit me up and ask
me questions and some of the questions I
get sometimes I'm like oh dear
like if you're talking to me like this
I'm gonna imagine if you were having
conversation with industry people you
are all out of order what kind of things
I like I mean just sometimes I just get
people just oh oh people just don't get
it you know and it'll be like hey you
know I saw you was doing such and such
I'm just wondering how I too can get
involved in that aspect of comedy and
I'll be like how are you do you do
stand-up no no no
I was just wondering cuz I saw you doing
it and I'm like oh dear I hope this
person isn't just wildly just hitting up
people across the country right you know
you're even asking even emailing clubs
like you know I booked my weekly show
and if somebody emails me and it's like
you know let me get a spot like not no
introduction no just it literally will
say just like yo let me get a spot you
like a bullet that's a whole message who
are you yeah like at least say hey Joel
yo we love a spy I think it's
professionalism yeah yeah you said when
you go to clubs conduct yourself
professionally yeah same thing when
you're not at the club but interacting
with professional people be professional
if you want to be professional you know
just be you don't you know and just just
you know don't be the you know cuz it's
been you know you work close sometimes
no oh yeah we don't don't do
such-and-such anymore because this comic
you know destroy this thing or this
Tommy this thing you're like right
people were coming here destroying
things
oh yeah like you know so well how was
getting a manager affected your career
ah it's been like I mean we're still
kind of in the you know building stages
no but it's but it's good cuz like I
said you have that thing where I said
earlier where somebody can speak for you
somebody you know like certain certain
things that like if somebody's
contacting me like hey I saw your um you
know I saw you your website and I was
just wondering if you could come do my
open mic spot you know do five minutes
I'm like that's not something I would be
like oh I should submit the bed I can
feel his presence you know like that's
just crazy you know boom but if
something seems like it might be like oh
like cuz I think at one point I got some
email where it was like you know I owe
you love for you to audition for this
thing and so that's the kind of stuff I
will forward her and go like have you
heard of this is this legitimate is this
real you know what you found out more
information for me no stuff like that
you know or sometimes if it's just
coming from a different voice it just
you know I think people are like oh I'll
respond you know so what what does a
manager what is like there what are
these ability yeah
find you gigs as well or what this more
like a mrs. and this is just me just no
do you want to know what man I just get
excited I was squealing I'm sorry purse
to me it kind of seems more like a well
like I'm gonna guide okay career now
will help guide you to you know
different things I think you should be
doing are things that we think together
and Trish you're gonna be doing cuz I
don't feel like it should be a part I'm
looking you again I'm sorry how can you
not know it's fine I like purses but um
yeah but to me it just it's more like a
like good managers I think are right
like guide you into certain things or
you know suggest like oh you should go
to this place oh you should go do this
thing or hey make a trip to go to LA for
a week so we can do this or you know
stuff like that or or hey you're gonna
you know like you're gonna be in this
festival you're gonna do like to me
that's kind of what I've what I've give
it cuz you'll sometimes meet people who
say that they're managers and it's just
like no you just want to say this so you
can take 10% of the nothing I'm making
yeah cuz I've I've had that before like
hey you want to manage you and then I'm
just like all you're doing is forwarding
me emails like this isn't you aren't
telling me whether or not you think this
thing could work for me you're just
sending me stuff to be like hey I told
her about a thing there's 10% yeah so do
managers do they get a 10% like the
bottom line like if a comedians like hey
will you come do this show with me it
had nothing to do with the manager will
they get percentage of that gig yeah
yeah of you I mean I don't know I'm not
like probing and like looking for a
specific angle on it it's really just
curiosity and yeah I mean unlike like
you know like but not like my car
or you know or if or my cruise ship
stuff like not that stuff but like you
know your you know all your other stuff
I mean all evens out yeah it's not like
yeah it's disproportionate or if it is
you can get out of it you realize it
really quick yeah that's cuz I had
someone cuz now I can talk about it but
I had somebody who was like that where
they were just like oh you do
colleges well obviously we get 10% of
that and I'm like but I'm already paying
a percentage to my college agent like
collagen yeah yeah I'm like why do you
get this too and all you're doing cruise
ships we get that too I remember these
people even asked me straight out
they're like what do you sell merch and
I was like yeah I got a cup I sell for
$5 they're like well when you go to your
shows mark now how many cups you sell at
the end a night did you give us a
percentage of the cold and then I was
like I maybe I'm like these are cubs
that I just bought and printed myself
right I'm and I'm like I'm doing this
but yeah but it would be was such a
nothing is hilarious but um yeah but it
was just like when I'm right I remember
sitting there going like you want cups
like cups that I I bought and never say
yeah and I'm like but you know the cups
are only $5 a cup and I'm like you want
10% of always made am I've been 15 or
something I'll like you want 15% of a
cop hmm and they were just like yeah
like I does that not make you know and
you know I remember telling mad about it
cuz I was like I first of all I'm afraid
of managers and then that was like me
and like nobody wants your cut funny
what are you doing like no nobody she
like no no you didn't you know she's
like no like no I was Lena this out so
you mentioned also yeah there's it's
almost like agents for everything I
guess we said cruises colleges you know
commercial agents you know act and
there's all that corporate or the
corporate agents to yeah sometimes
there's
like cause like my um college acres they
do some corporate stuff and they may
also like get people on ships and stuff
like that you know so is some some
people kind of do it all but and you
know I think like but I don't do a
person but I've seen people that are
comedians that are also speakers and
like there's like speaker you know
speaker agents yeah you can see yeah all
that kind of stuff too so yeah it's some
of some of everything
yeah is I've been looking towards and
this is really just in the past I mean
pretty much since I did my taxes and
added up everything from last year I was
like okay we need to make changes now
yeah so I've been transitioning into
just thinking of other streams beyond
just yeah you know 50 bucks a show right
at a comedy club you know that's not
sustainable for called yeah yeah and
also I've gotten to the mindset of where
I'm stopped I stopped fighting the
current and thinking of oh why am I not
getting booked at this club was wrong
with me here don't they know who I am
you know which they will and I'm selling
out you know clubs and then I can take
it off the top there and be like oh you
owe me for all the other times you
didn't book right no there's nothing
more that I'm hoping for I am I am
waiting for the day that I can tell
people oh really remember you don't if
2014 my google night you didn't want to
respond to my message right now um
that's my boyfriend stays late you got
an aggravation tax I'm like I want an
aggravation tax a lot of people know I'm
only partially kidding we all have a
little part of us you know look at me
man ready for my close-up right yeah
right like when people are you know
trying to get revenge against you know
what is it I remember my what's telling
me the best revenge I get someone you
break up with is to live well and I was
like or I live well and destroyed them
and I would like some payback no no no
you but you but yeah I think I think is
all with us a little bit to be like I
just can't wait to go I told you so
oh and also back to the manager
conversation you're not a minute I just
want to let people know I'm not an
expert so I'm Barry yeah buzzing oh man
I hear just other people are like you
know no she talked about like I am
basing on all like it's to me it's been
a now that I actually have a good
manager mm-hmm just like this is
somebody who guides your career and can
you know but yeah like you don't want
someone recommending you for things that
aren't a good fit like I had someone who
once was like hey I want you to read for
this role and they were like will and
I'll read it I said well you know that
role is topless and they were like you
know it's not and I said yeah it is and
they were like no it's not I go I just
read the breakdown for it and they want
you to be topless and I was like I don't
want to be topless and then they were
like oh okay nevermind I could see how
you might not want to do this I'm like
or you could've just looked at it first
I don't send me on things like that like
don't know I don't want that
recommendation you know so and that's
nothing - yeah make sure whoever it is
like it's a good fit - like you and a
president were good you know chatting
relationship talking talk you can call
him and hey is what I got going on you
know yeah and I and I kind of think
that's why I was all like there first to
where I was like what do managers are
doing right acally I'm like what are
they did he just take take agents are
the ones that are more like here's a gig
here there you go and you get why they
get 15 or 20 right yeah yeah yeah but
it's like I don't
it shouldn't I think it shouldn't be any
more than 20 I think you don't quote me
on that but I know it's 15 to 20 mm I
think cuz um I'm trying to think yeah
cuz I think when I had a cruise ship
agent I think it was 20 and I think
colleges this 20 I think yeah what I
have yeah cuz that's what's interesting
you said about managers is that it
should be more of like a there should be
a rapport there cuz yeah
Kevin Hartz manager Dave Becky he said
they've had a handshake agreement
there's no yes
yeah and that's how I'm and that was
nothing to like I remember when I was
all afraid he like when Matt and I were
talking I was like it or not get me made
me fine paperwork and she was like no
I'm not gonna make me is like I think of
some people will they do try to take
advantage of you you know there are
people who will go like oh well I think
you know that person seems to be
up-and-coming and I could capitalize on
that and then also you meet the people
who have no business managing anybody at
all and they they you know they latch
onto some comic and be like oh my god I
should I should manage you and then that
person is not even getting enough work
to sustain yeah you know having anything
other than themselves at that point so
yeah you're given some good red flags
like little things to look for and
things to look out for as well you know
yeah they're like I mean cuz I I mean
and it's like think you want people that
will you know meaning that's all
entertainment so everybody's gonna lie a
little bit you know everybody's gonna be
a little full of searching but I want
don't worry you're gonna lie to me the
least this is kind of what I want like
who's gonna tell me the least amount of
lies that I could work you know I'm what
it was analyzing cuz I had the UM you
know the one I mean I said he was my
cruise ship agent we did not get along I
mean I didn't feel like we got along at
all and I'm no longer with that company
and it was just like I always felt like
when I was cousin to the point I guess I
could make whoever you are with to you
want to feel like they support you and
you want to feel like they believe in
what you're doing and every time I would
talk I would feel like I'd be pulling
teeth like yeah I have enough material
yeah well do you really have my god 45
minutes and I'm like to curse them out
but it just hit me in the fields yeah
and but I felt it like I'm like yo
like you almost want to be like oh well
I know me it has 45 I know me it has an
hour not a bullet you have to prove do
you like I was hoping the reason that
you put me on your rosters because you
thought I was capable of it you know so
other things I think you want to work
somebody you know you have a good
rapport with somebody that you know cuz
sometimes stuff works out sometimes
stuff doesn't you know though you know
you want people that you feel like and
shout out to my college agents cuz like
they're super cool people and I'm like
you know if I hit them up about
something they've hey you know what I'll
get back to you I'll let you know where
something's coming up they let me know I
mean I get messages from them I talk to
them and I know what's happening like I
don't know if like with the because with
colleges they don't always have a check
right there on site so sometimes they'll
do the net 30 and sometimes it'll be oh
you know once the performance is
completed then we can put it into our
system bailing you to check into some
schools or oh we knew you were coming so
now we can you know right you don't get
the check when you get done with with
the college show and so they're always
good about telling me like okay you know
what you just finished such-and-such
school so we get a check and I send an
email hey Mia we deposit it you're
checking I'll be like mmm yeah there are
so many ways to use the skill of stand
up beyond just a traditional work your
way up in the club and pay your dues
that way
how are you looking what are kind of
different streams you're looking at as
well
like besides clips or the other things
just to just to bounce it off like the
pivot I'm making right now is I'm
looking at okay how can I get into the
corporate world more because I've done
some like people will pay for like team
building yeah sure I've been working
with a company a little bit and just
almost like hosting the event and
becoming like the facilitator the entire
event had a new energy into it ya know
and I was a trainer before so I know
that people use they new stuff like that
all the time yeah companies like in fact
at my old day job we hired an improv
group wants to like come in as part of
the team
it was like this is so cool I wonder
going I wonder if this could be done for
stand up you know so um but yeah but for
me like right now I'm just you know
clubs colleges just pretty much whoever
will will book me I'm not a good enough
of an actress to be like you know and I
think I want my own show that means I
have to memorize lines and I would just
scrap there's someone let me do what I
want to do on television and no one's
gonna let me do that because I'm not
famous but if I was it would be a sitcom
totally based around me doing whatever I
want it oh do you say you want to talk
show I did want you know I still do
yeah Joel yes I still wanna talk show
thank you remember I would steal look
cuz people love to tell me things I
would love yes I would love a talk shop
would love to go I just want to have
them glasses all like Oprah people go on
but that's what I want to say it I want
to go I was reading your book and on
page 37 you said I guess I just want to
say that once to somebody
are you still are you doing anything
towards that of course cuz out not of
course not cuz I just remembered just
now when you say that I was like maybe
that was something I said I want I need
a personality driven project I'll take
ten percent that ten percent I would
totally give you ten but if I do make
cups and say all them the Mia Jackson
talk show cut money of course as you get
your money give him a cut money I'm not
asking for much but since you came
you've been in the corporate world how
would you recommend me almost breaking
into that
um cuz I'm trying to think how we how we
booked sort of or got people like even
when the world like when it came to the
bringing the improv group II and like
people knew that I did stand-up and so
they were like well do you know anybody
and everybody knows stand-ups and improv
don't talk to each other I'm just you
know I don't talk to each other no but
but I didn't know people and so the
people that were in
but I knew like I reached out to them
and then like I think it was do more in
problem if you ever met them but um but
it was um but they came in and I
remember like no so Africa I think I
recommended him and then we got them
again for something else at the company
but it's but it just came from like them
going oh we know someone that does
comedy so it wasn't more like a oh we
should just reach out to the
administrative season because I've been
an administrative assistant at a company
before and have gotten stuff in and been
like I don't know what this is like I
don't I'm not gonna send this to my
manager but when people used to give me
gift cards for stuff I would go I think
I can pass this Oh cuz I remember
something you know somebody at one of my
dogs they wanted me to pass along like
some brochures or something to people
and I'm kind of like no I'm not gonna do
that but you did give me a gift card so
I will you know so so so so good so some
companies I knew what we had like bigger
corporate events like on it was when it
was stuff like oh this is the
company-wide something like whoever was
the coordinator of the event like they
their title that the job wasn't
something like oh that's the
entertainment director for our company
but it might have been if it was a
whatever department was sponsoring that
thing it might have been well so I guess
you could speak to some administrative
assistants cuz sometimes the executive
assistants or the administrative
assistants are the ones that are putting
on the event okay times they get
responsible for reaching out to two
different people and you know and just
like so assistant is their title that
would be great this is administrative
assistants you know and like I said but
with mine my was just like within a team
in a in a one big department and I know
you were comedian so you are convenient
so do you know someone who could come do
this thing and so that's you know so
even table stuff like that happens
referrals we're even again referrals
refer other key so that seems to be even
almost instead of trying to find new
connections it's assessing the ones you
have yeah yeah and like um I remember
somebody telling me once that um they're
like if you work with someone before
they're like every couple of years ever
couple months like go through and send
send the emails to that person you know
just and I hey how are you doing in
there oh fume in a while you know how
are you and then you kind of start a
report that way but yeah but I used to
be like said when I was when I was an
administrative assistant people would
call hey you know like I mean just even
like basic conference oh hey do you guys
feel you could call call anyway I mean
like I had people who asking me about
like what are your print services what
do you use what do you buy your ink
cartridge you know and I'd be like oh
and then that person would send me movie
tickets and I would go man I will make
sure we make sure we start using your
ink Thank You movie ticket basically I'm
saying I can be bought very easily um
you're not alone I'm sure that can be
within that cell industry yeah so some
and then there's um and then there are
some people I know some companies when
they do have bigger events if it's not
just like a like if it's not just
something contained to that company like
some people will use outside meeting
planners you know to put stuff stuff on
for them because they're doing something
on such a larger scare what scale where
it's not just oh this is in our off-site
building and we're gonna have lunch
today and then we're gonna bring in
somebody to we're gonna set up a
cornhole game out over in the corner you
know like it isn't more than just that
but like I remember I think like we had
our Christmas parties and stuff like I
remember the executive assistants and
admin assistants being the one that's
like I'm gonna book the venue I'm gonna
do this thing we're gonna get you know
all this stuff going but like sometimes
entertainment wise it would just be
referrals like I mean more yeah but some
people like I said they use meeting
planners they and like I said not a lot
of corporate companies aren't gonna have
just like this we have a dedicated
entertainment department because you
know like we're an IT company why would
we happen you know so so you just gotta
find those other ways to get into you
know even contacting some of the c-level
people are finding or looking at who the
c-level people are in the company what
is that well if you love like the um um
um chief executive officers
you know chief financial officer oh yeah
but but but like those people usually
have administrative assistants or
executive
like to the executive assistant of CEO
Mia Jackson and then that person is like
oh I got a flier for Joel buyers and
Joel buyer sent me some candy
boom I hope he's not trying to murder me
but if you send a gift car they will
know you aren't trying to murder that's
why I like the movie cuz I was thinking
oh Starbucks I was like never mind now
don't know I and that you know and that
was the gift card I had gotten but this
was years ago this for you woke we those
before last week
yeah we're not we won't go there this is
more of an education this is it but yeah
but somebody sent me AMC movie cards
like a desk and that's why I started
using that person's printing um I
started buying recycled ink cartridges
from that person because the guy would
call all the time telling me I'm gonna
see some movie card it's a movie or gift
cards for taking my call and I would go
you're silly
here's my dress did you everybody ever
reach out through LinkedIn maybe I go
that route is that - unprofessional
though let me see when I was doing an
admin stuff LinkedIn didn't exist
through that but um yeah just like a lot
of cold calls like on people with if
they were trying to push anything it
would be the use our services you hey
we're gonna have a you might be some
companies like oh we want to come in and
talk about a product so can you hand
these Flyers out because you want to
present this to these people in your in
your company you know so it would be
that kind of um I would get just
straight-up calls or just stuff in the
mail and be like what is what is this
but like once I said once I became more
over like hey I'm in I'm part of a
department and not the front line of
defense for something then a lot of that
stuff just became referrals cuz even now
like somebody from my old job who now
works in DC contacted me one day I was
like hey we're actually having an event
and our thing like are you would you be
available to do this thing but again
another referral because that person had
been tasked with it but they don't do
they don't book entertainment for their
company they just like can you find
somebody do you know somebody we're
gonna have this event and you know
people are in the meetings like oh what
if we do this or what do we put this
together so that's how a lot of it would
happen
I was at my old job what referrals this
used to be the universal currency pearls
is oh yeah I mean pearls recommendations
I mean it's always a that's how I've
gotten pretty much everything I've done
for the most part I mean like yeah I
mean like especially things I think
about any recent recent years is because
someone went oh you should take a look
at her oh you should should check me and
Jackson out you should you know get good
first though but get good first like
nobody want equality right nobody wants
to see you talking about nothing or you
get or you get an opportunity that
you're not prepared for you know were
the people that I got you know we had a
luncheon the other day and likes well
you don't want that to happen it's cool
to see you you did it and I'm trying to
follow your career path in that okay let
me get good at comedy and then try to
figure out a way to bring awareness to
this business I've grown so it's like
yeah you were funny first yeah I think
people need to understand yeah like I
honey first and then you got the
referrals because you were worth the
time don't ya two years in like were my
room yeah cuz I'd be like listen I need
to know what you did
like I remember what was that it was
some years ago when I did the Soul Train
Awards you know they were it was the
2009-2010 ten I wrote for the Soul Train
Awards and I got that because of a
referral big kitty shout-out to be
kidding honey can you sit in a writing
sample sure and I remember you know I
think the two years that I was involved
I got I got on air both years like just
like I was in a sketch in one of them
and then I was in the sketching and two
of them I think and I remember like
somebody contacted me and just going hey
like I saw you you know own thing like
how did you how'd you do that like I
want to know what you did cuz I feel
like I'm funny
and I'm like but everybody feels like
they're funny you know and again I
remember writing back and saying oh you
know I had to submit a writing sample
and I had to do this and I had to do
this and the response was okay thanks
[Laughter]
I've gotten that quite oh it's work
first woke up oh it's worse yeah yeah
nevermind I know yeah so a lot of people
just think you just you know they think
you just get up they think you just
things just came out of thin air they
think that it just just happy magic yeah
they think it just yeah and then you're
like oh no no you know like well I saw
you working as such as I was like how
did that happen I'm like oh well you
know I am was in clubs for 15 years
first open mikes I got my feelings hurt
I was sweating on stage I was damp and I
was embarrassed and then I got better
and then I got embarrassed again yeah
then and that's how I ended up that's
how I end up at Philips Arena guys by
being in pain yeah so was that the kind
of thing where it's like you know
there's a you got to put in a lot of
work yeah first you know and so yeah but
I guess I definitely get the how do i
you know and then you know I remember
somebody asking me one said oh I heard
that um somebody told me that it takes
like 10 years to find your voice I asked
a lot of people that so I'm asking you
what do you think and I was like that's
about right no but I'm saying like but
what do you think though and I was like
no no I'm telling you like that's the
same I'm giving you the exact same
answer no but what you don't understand
is I'm asking you and I went no that is
the answer and like and so sometimes
I'll get people asking me the same thing
over and over because they want to hear
something different cuz they don't want
to hear about the trade-off yeah they
don't want to hear that you've been you
know like just sweating it out you know
and performing in front of two and three
people booed getting yeah you gotten
booed before yeah yeah yeah I got em
over getting booed and getting um now
I'm gonna get booed um know what to say
this all happen within six months of
each other
Oh coz now I'm out table story [ __ ]
not even have this woman they ever uh
what was it
it was the Miller Lite contest thing a
few years ago and um this was like to
you cuz I think every year like I think
when you're Marlon Wayans was like hey
Marlon Wayans look him somebody funny to
make sure it was like ever hot really
was the money it was in your care for
horrible somebody funny him I was it I
think I think it would still cost was it
Center strange yeah yeah and I was there
and um just it just did not work and
like and it wasn't and I got booed so
much as it was half of the room was like
we want to get his look girl some claps
and then the other half of the room was
like and there were people that were
tweeting and Instagram and I have is a
groom at the top of people just like
who's this [ __ ] like God nobody we like
I think she's really funny you know
nobody like look no but I could remember
just feeling real damp and hot on stage
and that might have been because I was
wearing some sway issues in the summer
which is neither here nor there but
probably very important to why I was
sweating she's a big break but yeah I
just um yeah and I just remember going
like oh god like what I thought I was
good oh good and I remember II notice I
could I could tell she's a newer comic
and I was like like I have failed I
didn't I didn't want to talk about it
for a long time I was just like yeah
there was this theme where I got booed
but I was like oh but yeah but people
were just tweeting and then um a few
months later I did I did um what was it
sorry um I did a college show and it's
just I think there I actually got booed
at a college at keys they had all just
no kinda just stuff going on an
evolution in this the net that what
was bad because mom and dad what's to
know
and I'm like cussing out children and I
was like don't nobody care about just oh
you know got a lot I've got a degree
when you won't get chosen oh my gosh
during the school day university they
hated my goods like oh and then there
were other people who were tweeting me
saying stuff like um um cuz I want to
say my sister may have been in college
at a time at Georgia Southern I believe
and so I think she knew some people that
went there she was just like I think
people were saying me and then like some
people were you know kind of like oh
come on man this ain't how we treat
people that come to our school you know
so there were it was tweets of support
like a man I'm so embarrassed
messaging me on Twitter and you know I
was like um hey I'm sorry like that's
not representative of how our school you
know works but the thing was the public
but I can't sit there and go it was
their fault like it was like it was I
remember cuz the play wasn't that um I I
still remember that day like I went
because it's not far from where my
parents live the school is not that far
from there and I remember I had gotten
off work I think I took a half day and
then when I came down my mom was like
why don't you take a nap first well hold
on I got to do stuff and I just remember
being extremely tired mm-hmm didn't rest
or any of that stuff
and so I just I just I wouldn't in the
right mind space I wasn't prepared like
I said when I went in there I kind of
winning they're kind of you know not not
with an attitude but just kind of like
Oh like I'm exhausted I don't want to be
here and you know then some of the
students were like you know one of the
people on the shows like you're gonna be
like the person that was here last year
cuz we doesn't matter last year they got
booed off the stage
be like that person and I'm like no
don't be like that person and I'm like
you know who I am I was absolutely wrong
yeah but it was it was yeah but with him
six months it was like they were within
no matters yeah yeah they're within six
months of each other where I just
remember going like Oh God like what
have I done like I am a terrible
terrible comic again I was just like oh
god and I remember they broke out into
the electric slide-in mass after that
you know was like you know what I didn't
I can't even I don't even deserve to do
the electric slide with them cuz I did
so bad like it was such a bad set at the
end but I remember I was scared for a
long time just doesn't be like maybe I'm
not meant to be in front of very large
crowds you know maybe that's not oh
maybe this maybe I'm not supposed to
perform in front of more than 200 people
that's something out of 200 I'm not a
200 plus comic but wait when you're in
those slumps you'll convince yourself of
any absolutely then maybe and then if
that happened in October of 2012 the
college bombing then in June of 2013
that's when Chappelle came to the
tabernacle shows and I remember being
like oh god I really I really hope I
don't get booed in front of you're
getting booed because I was just like do
you know cuz the front of prior-year I'm
like I've had two shows in front of big
crowds where I'm like did not go well
and then I went and did that show and
and I remember looking at like I'm
looking at some of the Ticketmaster
comments people I it was just go out and
open the show she was great she was
amazing and I'm like yeah I did it but
some but also somewhere in between that
time from like the fall of 2012 into the
spring of 2013 like I had just um
um I started working out and I just like
I just mentally got better at a better
place I just got to just like I feel
better about myself I felt like I looked
better on stage and it just made like it
just made some change you know so I was
just like I can go do this I can perform
in front of this crowd I can do this you
know and anyway well and then I was like
I'm not embarrassed and but you know but
I can look at
oh the two stories and go like what was
I doing I'm like you know what I
wouldn't really repair it I was in my
head a lot and just kind of like just it
just you know he didn't work but yeah
they just was tough it was really tough
yeah do you find cuz I've gone through a
slump a little bit lately and then just
had like a recent like thing that kind
of like oh never mind maybe it's not all
so bad do you find there is like you
have found a balance when there's a low
you just got to keep perspective yeah
yeah there's a high around the corner
yeah just you just kind of assess like
you know like well what did I do
what'd I do wrong cuz I remember doing a
show was it last year year before but it
was like a Valentine's Day show and
those people were not trying to hear me
at all it that show cuz I'm like they
want to go home cuz it's Valentine's Day
they want they want to have hot lovely
relations yes they don't want to be in
here tonight watching me talk about
nothing and and what they were just kind
of antsy and talking and I was just like
oh you know gonna add a to word to
people and I was just like get them you
know huh and I just was like what's
wrong with you and he was like why don't
you why'd you act that way during the
show he was like Mia you were wrong but
you were wrong he was like you didn't
even he was like you didn't even try you
didn't try he was like you just whatever
I was like ah listen in any way so I'll
forget these people you know and I was
like yeah oh my god you know it's all
just like you're right but I but but it
but it just made me go like I remember
getting all huffy at the time and
getting attitude like how you gonna tell
me that what I'd be like no Dave word
the problem I'm like no it was a big
problem like I didn't get control of the
situation and so that's what I try to do
after show Ladell or I try to go even
when I get an attitude or when I get mad
and the next day I just have it go
alright like what now and I'm removed
from it and my feelings are just hurt
you know what what did I do like where
can I take some accountability for how
that show turned out because I'm here
just blame you wanna blame God listen in
on your own
there are some audiences were you like
these people are the worst you know but
then but but when you in situations
where I was like you know what they
weren't the worst because they were
responding to some of the other people I
just wasn't doing something to connect
with them and I got to figure out what I
was doing tonight not connect you know
that's so on point
the self awareness and self
actualization and like you said
accountability yeah that's that's gold
so Mia Jackson thank you for doing this
again
listen you're only the second repeat
guest you and Clayton English only food
so you know I'm done I'm done fighting
currents I'm following what's working it
out of here well I'm what are you coming
to hang out at least are you pride I
mean I'm booked
Saturday and I'm booked tomorrow Sally
answer's no so maybe Sunday okay maybe I
don't know when the festival ends though
I think it's Sunday little son of a go
easier I think it's I'm doing another
interview on Sunday so maybe I'll maybe
just stay out after the interview but
yeah you know no it's fine bye it's no
that's that's the thing I've learned
with everything like it is fine yeah cuz
I what was it can I say this to you
before like don't like you know I have
lots of things to say but like I can
like and even since jfl like I've had
conversations with other comics that are
just like they don't pick me you know
then forget the elmore how you know and
I was just like hey do you know how long
I've been doing colony before I you know
what I'm like you've been doing comedy
three days like calm down like you'll
like it's gonna be fine like you know
but I just remember going you know what
some things happened when they are
supposed to and I know it's a lot of new
agey and weird but it's like you know
what like I remember telling one of my
friends when I got I was like oh my god
I was like does it seem like every doing
comedy forever and then I you know got
it my friend was like you know what me
and I'm gonna point this out to you she
said look at your work ethic prior to
win she's like you know look at it now
since you only had to do comedy look at
your work ethic to when you still had
your day
job and you were pursuing comedy so she
was like so this tracks for a person
that's been going at it as hard as you
have in the past you know four or five
years she's oh it does make sense that
you would get it you know and I was like
you know yeah and some but it was it was
such a great thing to do but like I but
I can you know I see you know it's the
it's just those things where it's like
like you said you sometimes just have to
say to yourself like alright you know
what like if I get this thing I get and
if I don't get this thing I don't you
know and like I'm not supposed to do
everything like I would tell myself that
all the time like you ain't supposed to
do everything you're not a good fit for
everything right you're not supposed to
do everything some things you're
supposed to do something you're not
supposed to do you know so when I hear
people kind of get bent out of shape
about I didn't get paid for this
festival or you know I didn't get into
this thing running into that famous like
you know and that's okay like it's it's
okay you know and you know and that's
kind of you know and I've had
conversations were friends were like
well you could say that now because
you've done it you know you yeah thing
and I'm like but steal them like there
was a time where I had not done those
things you know and so don't tell your
person don't yeah yeah you know and
that's the you what does it do though
what is it The Four Agreements have you
ever heard of that mm-hm I forget the
author of the book but it's something
called The Four Agreements and one of
the things that it says like don't take
things personal it was like stuff's not
about you you know that's why I stopped
and when I say fighting the current it
is like that negative energy of how
you're not getting this festival I've
reached out to this club I've done well
there and they didn't rebook me and like
all this instead of like fighting the
current on why isn't this happening
focus on oh why is this happening yeah
this is where yeah moving and where the
momentum is yeah and so like I said I'm
very grateful for you know all the
things that have been able to do with
the things that I've been able to
experience and all the stuff and I went
out and you know and then sometimes when
you know some of those things happen
you're like I did that okay like cool
you know I got that's a cool thing to
happen and I have it being the part of
my life and you know and so so just not
just you know but other people that are
out there there too listening it's like
just you know don't worry about it you
know like it's I mean
you wanna worry about it but it's like
it's fine like don't think because you
know some two days and you're supposed
to get you know the festival I don't
think because you were doing something
you know you've been going hard at it
for months that mean you know cuz I know
it takes a you know it takes a deal if
it takes the process so like I said when
I got to do jf I was like mm-hmm
validation you know like oh but you know
but I you know I'm not well cuz it my
friend was just like no look at your
work ethic she was like a work ethic
she's like it matches to why you would
have you know why you got it you know
what I was like that work ethic don't I
are you big on goal-setting - uh here
and there I probably should be a little
bit better about it but um one of the
things I used to try to take that was
like - one of the things I would take
for my job that was the face of teach us
about SMART goals
hmm you know the smar T okay goes when
you make your goals specific to make it
miserable and I think I see that action
so is either actionable or accountable I
forgot what the are was but the T is
time based so you set up goals by saying
stuff like instead of going
I want to lose 40 pounds you go I want
to lose 40 pounds by July 1st 2018
because now you have that time in your
head to go now I got something to work
for because otherwise you just leave
something open-ended you know and then
it's funny because one of the when I was
moving last year I actually found some
of the stuff I had written down like
years ago where I think one of things on
there was like I want to do jfl I want
to be on Last Comic Standing I wanna I
want a college-aged and I was like oh my
god I guess I'm throwing stuff where I'm
like all this stuff happened I was like
I did those things and my those things
happen I'm like I did write it down
somewhere I didn't write a date mixer
which I probably should have but it was
just cool to go oh you know that's a you
know Wow so but yeah but it helps for
like material wise - like oh you know I
want another five minutes you know what
I'm gonna try to set a goal to go and
you know by two months from now I wanna
have any five minutes and then so in
your head you go alright we're gonna
have a new five minutes by this date
then I gotta be on stage every night
until that date mm-hmm just part of the
work people don't want to heart of the
work looking a secret
how do you have you will you got to be
on stage every night of your life it's a
lot of work no secret but to do the work
and some people don't want to do to work
so that's not for everybody
mmm but it is for you it is that hope so
yeah
and so I previewed that was that was a
cue for you to say any list for you to
join it that's fine Joel you know you
are the hardest-working man in comedy
good not the funniest but he tries the
table and you were very funny I
appreciate it I do love your irreverence
on stage I just know where the first
time I saw you back and you had your
mustache dude is just talking [ __ ] about
everybody or like you know so I was like
I've never seen the price just look
common to be like all right ma'am mm-hmm
what the mustache - yeah you were in the
mustache I remember the mustache era I'm
not like the non mustache error though I
appreciate yeah I feel I just changed
your career no mustache
see it's all that's all trying to look
that's what really what it's all about
no mustaches and heading goals boom
that's going for the women too because I
need to go get my wax today well before
we get out of here
okay is there anything else you want the
world to know uh you know if you can go
to my website
Mia jackson.com I also have a fan page
which on on the Facebook's which is a
video of mine about me being tall that
people keep watching so finger has like
three million fan page went from like I
think I got like a thousand fans and I
was just like this is I have three
thousand likes in one week I was like
what happened I'm like it's been super
cool so like yeah so and that just
happened organically yeah you just woke
up I'm like oh this light do blue F
Stevie shared it and it was funny
because they shared it before and then
all of a sudden like people were like oh
you know I saw this on my timeline and I
saw this thing and like I think my
boyfriend say someone was like hey did
you know Mia had this video and he was
like yeah how was the hair when it
wouldn't have nobody
just like some random person that he
knew there was like oh look at this you
know a tagged a minute and he's like
he's like I guess a lot of people are
seeing this video and like people who
just been a bunch of tall people hit me
up and going like oh my god this is my
life this is my life you know so it's
been super cool so I don't fanpages just
come here me a jack on Facebook you know
I'm on Twitter and Instagram at Mia
comedy I don't really tweet a whole
whole lot of more of a retweet er yeah I
don't really tweet either yeah but I do
I will take some snapshots and put them
on Instagram I know I will do that let
the people know that you're beyond bangs
now you guys'll get that fool hey you
know what I just cuz I have bangs for so
long where I was like you know what I
would like to know what it feels like to
do like this once I just I just want to
look at people go hypnotize that was
dramatic and is main and doesn't look
right
but nonetheless you know how I feel and
you know how I feel about you Mamma Mia
so thanks for taking the time to do this
Thank You Joel alright have a good one I
think that's al okay I think that's it
are we still on we are still on live did
anybody watch us
it looks like although some people come
in and if people say stuff yeah I can't
see love me some me a Jackson whoa whoo
Mia is trying to live labeled water
means you made it oh look it oh that's
right I get to keep label water
capturing gold yeah love Mia yeah people
were commenting hey now well did that
just die nothing could be it well that's
perfect timing then perfect
alright well thanks for taking the time
I appreciate it
I breath